but that's a question that I actually
wanted to ask all you guys when you're
talking a second ago about like media
narratives I I get asked this all the
time as somebody who left the left and I
ended up becoming a republican
um in my opinion you know I used to hate
Fox News as a liberal I used to think
the Fox News was everything that they
said was a lie in some sort of
conspiracy theory and that they were
Doling out misinformation
now you know I've spent a lot of time
watching Fox News over the last four or
five years and I don't feel that way
anymore I do believe that they are
absolutely biased I think they
absolutely have a point of view that
they're trying to push but I don't see
examples of them blatantly lying and
creating misinformation and creating
completely false stories but I do see
that from left-wing media all the time
so do you think it's equal because I get
asked this question all the time people
are like oh well Fox News does that too
do you do you think they do msnbc's
owned by Comcast which is owned by
BlackRock I don't know how deep it goes
on Fox's end uh I think Fox what is it
Fox 20th Century Fox is owned by Disney
at this point does what's Fox news on
Fox news is I think it's still News Corp
right I don't know how deep BlackRock
has their technology Fox doesn't play
you know it's crazy that we're at this
point where I used to I I was talking
about this I used to watch scene nice to
have it on all the time and then one day
it was just a trump panel and I was like
is it isn't something happening and I
turn on Fox News and they're all like
riots erupting Iran and I was like oh
wow and I'm watching video footage of
these rights and then later there's like
a big storm I turn on CNN and there's a
panel talking about Trump and then I
change the channel and it's Fox and
they're like prepare for the storm big
storms coming here's what people are
saying and I was just like CNN is not
news it is it you know what I think Jeff
Zucker was a reality TV Guide and so he
approached CNN
actually let me let me stop before
saying CNN I'll tell you exactly what I
experienced with Fusion this was the ABC
News Univision joint venture
I leave Vice I join fusion and for the
first six to eight months they were like
we're gonna do news
we we added that a show about drug
cartels and like federal agents and
Mexican federal agents going after them
and then one day they were just like
we're changing things up they hired a
new editor-in-chief
whose Twitter profile was down with
whiteness and he's like a white guy and
it was a Black Fist and I was told that
they were shifting into Mission driven
storytelling um and then I was told that
because young people are progressive
that's what they're going after they
want to Target young people and young
people are progressive so that's the
narrative that they're pursuing so all
of a sudden there was this shift where
it was like tell the truth to
side with the audience
tell them what they want to hear right
and that's what happened there you go
and that was that was 2014. right the
idea I think and then CNN obviously
adopts a similar right the CNN and all
these media Outlets adopted the exact
same thing they you know look look at
this show
we're not the most tribal show but
there's tribalism entrenched in what we
do of course because everybody is got a
perspective we're clearly in the right
wing sphere of influence whatever you
want to call it including Libertarians
conservatives and post-liberals we uh
have direct disagreements with
establishment media establishment
personalities and the leftists who
outright support them so that's there
but if you if you take a look at the
prominent right-wing voices they're like
middle of the road if you take a look at
the left they're hard left
pro-establishment right so when you have
you have the left claiming and I mean
the legit left the Socialists Joe
Biden's bad we can't support him
we all voted for him and we think you
should vote for him too like that was
the funniest thing watching these
socialists be like
we don't like Joe Biden but you have to
vote for him and I was like this dude is
the epitome he's like he's like Goldman
Sachs you know big Banker Elite
corporate neocon neolib for what reason
would any leftists support that I guess
because they're fascists or whatever no
they don't have principles they
literally do not have principles what's
most important to them is trying to
establish a specific social order and
however they have to get their hands
dirty along the way they're willing to
as long as they end up getting the
pieces in the right place eventually and
this is interesting because uh you you
asked me before the show if I was
conservative now and you know talking
about walking away and I said no I don't
think so I think the issue is just as I
mentioned a moment ago if you believe
the lies or not if you if you trust the
narrative from The Establishment or you
question it is what really separates the
spheres of influence yeah so when you
see uh we did this thing with a
ground.news you can look up someone's
news consumption bias invariably
you pull up a left-wing personality and
it'll say all of like 80 or 90 of their
news consumption is left-wing sources
you pull up people like you know Michael
malice or me and it says a balance of
Left Right and Center mine I think is 55
left-wing sources then like 20 Center
and the rest is I think mine was 30 or
35. but then a lot of conservative
personalities are like 60 conservative
and then like 15 and 15 of Centrist or
left wing but they have way more
left-wing news in their diet than the
left has the other way around so you'll
you'll see that then what happens is we
bring someone on the show this like
former conservative guy and he outright
told me the Joe Biden quid pro quo thing
didn't happen I mentioned I was like so
you get Joe Biden saying you know SOB
the guy got fired that didn't happen and
he like smirks and I was like he said he
couldn't let that stand or something
yeah yeah I can't let that sound that
didn't happen and I was like yes it did
and he's like no no it didn't I was like
okay and I pulled the video up and I'm
like here's a video watch it and he was
like oh now I'm like and like what are
you serious you didn't Google it you
just heard it you thought it was true
that's a thing man the uh the Covington
kid stuff
I don't just believe it people are like
you ought to see this man people on the
right were critical of them and I was
like well what happened and we have a
lot of that going on right now like
there was that story of that uh uh that
young young girl in the school who was
sexually assaulted in Loudoun County and
everyone on the right is just saying it
was a trans person and I'm like that was
never part of the story they just
started saying that and I'm like if you
actually look it up the kid never said
they were trans at least that's my
that's my understanding having read the
story I was like if someone says
something happened I don't care from the
left or right I'm gonna read it it turns
out reality has a conservative bias
at least in my investigation in my doing
of Journalism and fact checking that's
what I found the left lies about
everything
should we do the list again
yeah Russia gate Ukraine gate uh Jesse
smallettes Michael Brown Ahmed Arbury
what are we missing Trayvon Martin wow
the media actually George Floyd
Charlottesville the media oh yeah Joe
Biden's whole campaign oh yeah lies
non-stop yeah and then they and then the
left tries to talk about the Republicans
and I'm like yeah who's praising Mitch
McConnell right now right I don't know
anybody who's actively in politics like
that's a great guy I'm really a big fan
of him but what is he even saying in
terms of facts nothing
so
I don't consider myself conservative I
consider myself someone who is
interested in what's true and what's
real you said something earlier that's
interesting because I think a lot of
people problem they're having is when
they hear something that they don't
necessarily want to believe they just
immediately say that's not real no but a
good a strong mind is capable of tending
an idea without believing it or
disbelieving it just allowing it to
exist and considering it well what you
just described is literally the
experience that I had that created the
sort of epiphany sorry that created sort
of the Epiphany for me that
um began the Journey of me walking away
because it's uh not to bore anything
okay
um after Trump got elected you know I
had voted for Hillary I was devastated
and um I was really acting out about it
I was really angry and one of the things
that I said was in January of 2017 so he
was a around the time he was about to
take office I went on Facebook and I
blasted conservatives in this post where
I just said you know I'll never be able
to understand how anyone could vote for
a man who was capable of standing before
a cheering crowd and mocking a
reporter's disability do you remember
that one yeah and that's when um
somebody that I knew she was my
babysitter when I was a kid this woman
Diane she was always a conservative but
she reached out to me privately on
Facebook with this video called
debunking the Trump disabled reporter
and she was like you know I'm just
wondering have you seen this you know
I'm not I'm not trying to start a fight
with you but I remember my instinct when
I just reading the title of the video I
was so enraged that she would try that
anyone would try to debunk that he did
that because I was like but I saw it I
saw it with my own eyes I know he did it
I seen and told me he did it and um then
I decided yeah then I decided to watch
the video because I um I thought to
myself well it's going to be really
clear that this was like right wing
propaganda and Fox News brainwashing so
then I can tell her how stupid she is
for falling for it and I watched it and
I it was like I almost dissociated from
my body because my brain was like
screaming at me like oh my God I don't
think he mocked that reporter's
disability but my heart was like going
yeah but we hate him but we hate him but
we hate him and I had to watch it four
times before I could reconcile within
myself that I I was wrong and but then
it took me at least another week or two
before I was able to go back to Diane
that woman and be like
okay I I I'm I'm I may be changing my
mind about this one thing not about
Trump but about this one incident but
that it that set me down the road of
trying to figure out what was going on
with the media and I want well I just
want to make a point here I remember
that story as well and and when I heard
it I didn't look too deeply into it I
thought maybe I mean I think it's
horrible if he said something like that
of course it turned out to be fake news
because basically everything they say
turns out to be fake news but even so
even if he had done something as
horrible as mock somebody with a
disability because of Hillary Clinton
there are slave markets back in Libya
she completely decimated a country and
I'm sorry but that's worse that is so
much worse even if Trump actually did it
which he didn't it is worse to destroy
an entire country to the point where
slavery has returned to the region so I
didn't I didn't vote in 2016 because I
was just like are you kidding me Donald
Trump and Hillary Clinton I heard what
Trump was saying but I was like please
I've heard this all before it's the back
and forth nonsense but I I think it'd be
real hilarious if Trump ended up winning
just because it's Trump and then when
Hillary lost it was just so hilarious
but my so um when it came to Joe Biden
versus Trump
I I was I was flabbergasted at the
leftists who were like we're gonna vote
for Joe Biden and I was like
Joe Biden was the vice president of
Barack Obama the National Defense
authorization act indefinite detention
Provisions expansion of the war in the
Middle East expansion of drone strikes
the bombing of civilians and then saying
oh but their military age males the
extrajudicial assassination of American
citizens and I was like you screamed
that George W Bush was Hitler and now
you've got the vice president of a guy
who killed American citizens without
charge or trial I'm voting for Trump
because what he he was he was no new
Wars there were there were there were
more drone strikes as we were pulling
troops I was like okay look Trump's not
that bad right I was like you can I hear
all the complaints left makes about him
I think his attitude his his character
was like Unbecoming of a presidential
office all that stuff matters to a lot
of people decorum does matter but for me
I'm like it matters relatively little
compared to a booming economy in 2019. I
don't blame him for covet I don't blame
Joe Biden for coven but then looking at
Joe Biden in the election and I was like
if that guy gets elected we'll be right
back in Syria we're going to have we're
gonna have new war mark my words it is
going to get worse and Donald Trump had
some good second term policy positions
so I said okay what do we get wow man
let I want to make sure everybody hears
this when you go to the Gas Pump and you
see that little Joe Biden that says I
did that that's not a joke Joe Biden
shut down Keystone Joe Biden introduced
new regulations on gas he banned uh he
put He put a freeze on oil and gases on
Federal Land there's a lot he's done we
had that video from Holly where he goes
through all of the policies and you know
why Joe Biden did it climate change now
I'm not I'm not making a moral statement
on climate change I think pollution and
all this stuff is really really bad I
think there are issues with these
massive population centers uh
overpopulating or polluting but if you
are wondering why your gas prices are
high it is because the people who are
scared about climate change are enacting
policies specifically because of climate
change they are saying they are doing it
and it's causing economic crises
if you're if you're cool with that
because you think climate change is bad
well just admit it that's fine I'm not
issuing a moral statement but Joe Biden
literally did this because of climate
change and now we've got reports that
Farms are being paid out to farm they're
being paid to build solar Farms instead
I mean it's very obvious what they're
doing just not telling people but that's
the reason if you're a climate change
activist be proud those high gas prices
mean less people will drive in lower
carbon emissions and if you are a middle
American working class person who's
struggling to pay your bills that's why
it's happening but do you do you I
honestly do you feel like your words
will resonate with these people I mean
this kind of goes back to the
conversation you I were having before
the show I mean like
if if Trump were to run again are enough
people getting it
that it actually would make a difference
because I actually believe that a lot of
people on the left are willing to pay
six dollars a gallon for gas or more if
they believe that we don't have Hitler
in office again well I just want to say
this I mean your former babysitter had
faith that she could reach you right and
it worked right it worked when I was
faced with the realization that
something that I okay here's the thing
I learned that my uh my feelings were
being manipulated by the people that I
trusted I trusted CNN I thought that
they were honest and I hated people like
Donald Trump and I hated people like
Republicans because I thought that they
were bad people I thought they were
people that did things like make fun of
disabled people and everyone laughs and
cheers but as it turns out to me it's I
say this all the time you know and as a
gay person I always say this like the
left will pretend like they're the
they're the people that care about black
people and brown people and LGBT people
and all this stuff but the thing is
they're actually lying and manipulating
and exploiting all of these people to
get them to think the way they want them
to think and behave and vote the way
that they want them to vote I will any
day of the week take the enemy that will
look into my eyes and say I don't like
gay people I do I just like I'll never
be down with you I don't like you then
the person who says no no I'm your
friend I'm on your side I'm here to
protect you but they're actually lying
to me and manipulating me and that's
what I discovered through that that I
experience
but yeah what I want to say is are
people getting the message it depends on
how you all at home are delivering the
message if you have someone who is deep
blue vote blue no matter who going to
them and being like it's your fault that
gas prices are so high because Joe Biden
and all and and his climate not going to
work you can do two things me I prefer
the middle of the road straightforward
approach where when I'm talking with
someone who I know might not agree I'll
just be like man you see those gas
prices and they'll go yeah dude I'll be
like that's crazy what is it it's like
six bucks in Pennsylvania it's like
almost upwards of eight dollars in some
parts of California but hey man look
what we what we're seeing Joe Biden he
wants to fight climate change you know
so they want to shut down Keystone
Pipeline because they don't want the oil
moving through and then you get
speculation which traps prices I mean uh
Russian Hot Stuff plays a role but these
prices were skyrocketing before that so
look I mean if you guys want to be
serious about climate change this is
what happens that is an effective
message they might say yeah I get it
that's bad and I'm suffering because of
it or you can do the even more
manipulative which is you see gas prices
eight bucks a gallon in California bro
high five you know those means it means
no one's driving good they shouldn't be
driving anyway if they can't afford
electric cars these people think oh I
can come out and talk about climate
change but they do nothing they keep
eating they keep guzzling they keep
flushing their toilets they take half an
hour showers during droughts good I hope
they cry every time they see that eight
dollar per gallon price and that's Joe
Biden who did that Joe Biden sent a
strong message to these American
gluttons who are burning through carbon
every single day we will end climate
change mark my words and Joe Biden will
do it and then regular people are going
to be like that was psychotic that's
what you say in the intersection before
you drive up in your Tesla to the guy
next
so that's the more manipulative approach
where you make someone be like that's a
crazy position I don't want gas prices
this High I'm not a fan of that but that
is you know I mean it's it's it's yeah
you have to go there it's like black
propaganda it's like shocking someone
with you know what's going on but I mean
I gotta be honest you don't even need to
do that because maybe just show them a
video of someone you know at like the
DSA convention where they were like my
name's John he him can people stop
clicking their pens because it's driving
my anxiety and then and then someone
gets them go stop saying guys and then
they're all yelling I'm like just show
them show them that video but but in all
reality the way to effectively give
someone the message is just to be polite
about it and say
Joe Biden said he want to fight climate
change so he passed some regulations
that caused the hiccups in the in the
energy sector he's not responsible for
all of the escalation of gas prices but
he played a big role I mean a year
before he came in office gas was like
two bucks now it's at like four to five
bucks so I mean it's obvious that you
know climate change policy I also kind
of stopped playing the game of trying to
change people's minds in one
conversation and play more of the
chipping away with just honesty and
kindness and listening to them because
they'll you know they're probably not
completely wrong about everything anyway
so it's nice to hear that's a good point
well no I mean there was an old saying
in every heresy there's a kernel of
truth I mean people believe things
because there is like some shred of
goodness there that they're trying to
scrape at and if you can figure out what
that little kernel of goodness is you
can show them the truth in how it really
fully embodies that I'm not saying it
always works well look what I am saying
I I agree with what Ian is saying that
there is there is something there about
like trying to figure now obviously we
have people in this culture who are like
completely bad faith actors are totally
moral lead to Brave but I'm saying like
someone you might meet in your everyday
life who could be persuadable so yeah I
think it's it's it's the left and not
the right right this is just reality the
right has post liberals these are people
who are the walk away people yeah
they're still very politically liberal a
lot of issues but they have aligned
themselves now with Republicans Pew
research showed that what they call the
stressed sideliners lean right on
political issues and it's probably
because the left keeps moving further
and further left like that Elon Musk
meme so when you see uh there's one
thing right now uh about me because I'm
I'm I've staunched 2A people are
wondering what positions I've changed on
I went from
I think guns are cool maybe we can have
some you know simple gun reforms that
might make everybody happy too not all
guns like guns are legal two-way if
you've got a problem with you gotta
change the Constitution
so I said in on an episode that the
second amendment protects the right to
keep and bear nuclear arms and
biological arms but I'm not wrong now
just because second amendment protects
it doesn't mean it's legal you can do it
or you should be able to do it so they
take a clip of me cut out the context
where I'm like people should have people
have the right to have nukes and and
Ian's like in biology weapons I'm like
absolutely and then they cut up the part
where I'm like that doesn't mean they
should it means that when the second
amendment was codified in the
Constitution people had warships that
could flatten coastal cities and the
founding fathers knew that and were like
you can have it the right to keep in
barhams and so there's a lot of
sophistry in the Second Amendment
argument where they say like but a
well-regulated militia that has nothing
to do with what the actual prescription
of the Second Amendment is they're
saying because of this need the people
have a right to keep in bear arms and
arms means arms does it say except
nuclear in the Second Amendment it
doesn't should it I perhaps it should
and that's something we will need to
change but that's that's something I
I've changed on for sure now what
happens is
in this whole issue they're sharing that
club out of context and then they create
fake context around it yeah and so after
they post that clip the morsel of Truth
Sheamus mentioned they then will add
something like and after this Tim said
this which I didn't say and then people
believe it because they saw a video and
then saw someone telling them the story
someone will say Tim Poole thinks
everyone should have a nuclear weapon
because he wants Ximena to be wiped out
here's the video here's proof and then
people go wow then they say Tim Poole
also claims that China manufactured
kovid to wipe out white people or
something like that which is like
something they're actually trying to
claim and these are high profile
left-wing accounts that's why I say when
you look at the right they the reality
has a conservative bias at least for now
maybe it'll change in 10 years what do
you mean what does that mean exactly it
means so uh Stephen Colbert the famous
quote reality has a liberal bias and
what the point he was making I guess was
that the liberal media as conservatives
call it tends to be true and their fake
news therefore reality must have a
liberal bias the reality is today if
you're talking to a conservative
personality Ben Shapiro great example if
you listen to Ben Shapiro you are 99 of
the time going to hear the absolute
truth to the best of his ability I don't
mean like the dude is omniscient but
he's going to be like we got a new
report coming off the New York Times
that says yeah we have a new repair for
the new account today this is what it
says like this is why they're absolutely
wrong but he will tell you what they're
saying Jack of The Young Turks will just
say nonsense right yeah and if you if
you watch his show uh this is why you
know you watch The Young Turks they'll
just say things that are Plum not true
or they'll just make dramatic
personalized like personal arguments
that have nothing to do with the issues
man Shapiro uh he told us he's like I
don't debate people I have discussions
with them but they're you know the left
will constantly be arguing so what do
they do the video that goes viral of Ben
Shapiro is some kid being like well you
can't please your wife and then the left
is like oh and they'll high-five each
other and I'm like okay why would why
would anyone want to be associated with
that and what does that have to do with
the with the principled arguments we're
having thus you talk to someone on the
right you'll end up hearing closer to
the truth than the left
yeah I think I agree with that it's only
because this liberal economic order has
its fangs in the neck of the American
citizen thanks for checking out this
segment from the timcast IRL podcast if
you want to watch live you can check out
this channel Monday through Friday at 8
pm and don't forget to smash that like
button subscribe to this Channel and if
you want more unfiltered and uncensored
content with all of these guests go to
timcast.com and become a member all of
these guests you know and love in
exclusive segments on our website where
we are unrestricted in what we talk
about so you'll definitely not want to
miss it thanks for hanging out we'll see
you all next time